>> So, our next speaker is
actually Maxim Grechkin,
from the University
of Washington,
and he's going to
talk about EZLearn.
>> Thanks for the introduction.
Quickly mention, this
is a joint work with
[inaudible] from Microsoft
Research and my advisor,
Bill Hall, from
University of Washington.
So, the motivation for this work
comes from bio-medicine.
We are looking at increasingly
a cheaper and cheaper
sequencing technologies,
that produce more and more data,
that is then being
pushed into repositories,
like Gene Expression
Omnibus, ArrayExpress,
that have millions of
samples corresponding to
potentially billions
of data points,
and it's almost 40 terabytes
of data in ArrayExpress now.
The trouble though is that,
even though there are
a lot of data is there,
data annotation is
kind of lacking.
So, this graph shows
exclusive growth on
submitted data samples,
but as you can
see on the bottom,
the number of curated samples
is growing slowly,
because they're
doing it manually.
So, we want to automate this
curation of scientific data.
Specifically, gene
expression data.
And the most natural
first step annotation
is just a tissue sample.
Is it a liver cell?
Is it a kidney cell?
And there is
a project spearheaded
by Chan Zuckerberg Initiative,
that tries to actually
build a Human Cell Atlas.
So it's a very
important problem,
and we have a lot of
data collected already
on legacy technologies
in those repositories,
and we want to annotate it.
Well, so you might
ask that this,
we can just search, so this
repository has a Search Bar.
What happens if you type
things in that Search Bar?
Well, it turns
out that Precision
and Recall are pretty low,
so if you search for liver,
less than half of the stuff
that you get out is
actual liver and so on.
So, let's formulate the problem
a little bit more concretely.
So, we have a repository that
contains a bunch of samples.
Each sample, each data item,
consists of a data sample,
which for Gene
Expression data sets,
you can think of as a vector
of 20,000 real values,
and there's also often
a text description.
So, people are uploading
those data items into
the repository for
other peoples to use,
so they describe those items.
Those descriptions
can vary in accuracy.
So sometimes, the description
will explicitly
mention the tissue.
Sometimes, an
example on the right,
it will be more cryptic,
it will use some abbreviations.
And in other cases, it
will be completely missing.
And to point out,
we now know about
5,000 different human
tissues in the predefined
Ontology in science,
and more and more different
cell types are being
discovered every day with
advances in technology,
just like Single
Cell Sequencing.
Also, [inaudible] I'm
going to show results of
our approach on
a different data set
from the project,
called VizioMetrics,
which is a project that tries
to look into scientific images,
and tries to classify
figures from scientific papers
into different types,
into different
visualization types.
The most natural thing to do is,
data annotation is
just a classification.
So, if you have a classifier,
you can get labels and
your problem is solved.
So, what's the bottleneck here?
Well, the bottleneck
is that you have to you
have to find
labeled data somewhere.
So, you labeled
a bunch of samples
yourself or you somehow
got labeled data.
And in this case, you label
bar chart and pie chart.
But then, you will inevitably
miss samples in the longer
[inaudible] this particular case,
you'll miss a phylogenetic tree,
maybe a picture of a platypus
or something like that.
And where do we get
that labeled data to begin with?
You can crowdsource it but
even in figure
annotation example,
explaining people in
the Mechanical Turk the type of
this visualization or type of
this visualization
might be complicated,
and if you want to
ask them to annotate
thousands of different
human tissue samples,
it's going to be hopeless.
So, you have to either hire
expensive experts,
do it yourself,
so this kind of bottleneck
of this approach.
There are smarter tricks.
So, there is a paper and nibs.
Last year, two years ago
on data programming,
where you write
labeling functions,
which produce you
noisy heuristic labels,
and different different
Labeling Functions
can produce different labels
for the same sample.
And then they have a framework
to produce a trading data
set out of those
Labeling Functions
or you can use
Zero-shot learning.
So, Zero-shot learning
approaches that allow you
to skip labeling
some of the classes.
But that kind of
assumes that you have
labels for other
related classes,
and you know the structure
of your label space.
So, what we're going to do
is we're going to
take advantage of
our specific problem formulation
and introduce an approach
called, EZLearn.
And specifically, what we
observed in the problem
that we're working with,
is presence of
this Organic Supervision.
Organic Supervision, we
define it as two components.
First component is a Lexicon.
So, each label that
we are trying to
predict is not
just an abstract entity.
It actually contains
an English word that
represents this,
it's a liver, we
know the word liver.
And then, in sciences,
we actually have
those ontologies,
where we might have some
synonyms for liver not actually
all in synonyms but some of
the synonyms for
different classes.
And also, people who
produce this data,
they would have
text descriptions.
Sometimes, most of them,
their description
will be pretty noisy.
But occasionally, they would
mention an original text,
an original term by name.
So for example, in
the figure comprehension case,
this caption of
this particular image,
explicitly mentions that
this is scatter plot.
So, to use this information,
we introduce an approach
we call EZLearn,
which essentially combines
Distant Supervision
and Co-training.
So, we use Distant Supervision,
which is an idea of using this
extra information
from Ontology and
text description to find
us initial set of labels.
And then we train an auxiliary
classifier that works in
a text domain and
predicts the label.
And that output of that
classifier are used to train
the main classifier from
the original data domain.
So, either Gene Expression
data or figure values.
Classifiers, we use
it pretty simple.
So, we don't want
to assume that you
need to have
sophisticated classifiers.
Have linear regression
for the data domain
after some deep future
transformations.
And then, we use fast text
for the text domain.
And so, before we evaluate,
let me describe the tasks
in a little finer detail.
So we have over 100,000
Gene Expression samples in the
repositories that
we're looking at.
There are almost 5,000
different tissue types
that want to predict.
Each on average,
those samples have descriptions
that mention three and
a half different labels.
So, we have this set
of noisy labels.
And on the other end
of the spectrum,
for images, we have
over a million images.
We have a growing Ontology
of figure types that we
are coming up with
more and more types that we
want to annotate every time.
But then, most of
the captions don't explicitly
mention the figure type.
And so, also for evaluation,
because we have an Ontology
that we are trying to
predict labels from,
we want to take advantage of
the Ontology and
evaluation step as well.
So, we're using Ontology-based
precision and recall,
where we propagate labels
from a correct prediction
and sort of from a correct label
and from a predictive label
up to the root of the Ontology.
And then, measure Precision
And recall in a standard way.
This allows us to capture
differences between being almost
right and being close to right,
and being completely far off.
And so, looking at
the tissue annotation example,
we compare with
the previous state of
the art approach
that was trained on
15,000 manually labelled data
samples, It's called URSA.
And looking at the area
under precision recall curve,
we significantly outperform
this previous approach.
We'll also see that
if we use coEM,
a variant of Co-training,
using their 15,000 samples,
we get improvement.
So, the advantage here is that,
URSA just used their
15,000 samples.
A coEM would use that
15,000 label samples,
and then about
100,000 of the rest of
the samples that don't
have explicit labels
but it would iterate
and improve the labels.
I'm interested actually
if you have access
to that entire repository and
just do distance supervision,
you'd do pretty well.
And then EZLearn has
been a combination of
Distance Supervision,
and coEM does better
than either of those,
showing that both components
are important.
So, those are
precision recall curves
for tissue annotation example
in the left and figure
comprehensions example
on the right.
And blue is our method,
and red is previous state
of the art approach,
and green dot is
what you get if you
just search using
Distant Supervision.
Also, we want to investigate
why exactly that happens.
On the right, we vary
the amount of unlabeled
with the amount of data
without explicit labels that
we feed into
either EZLearn or coEM.
And we see that,
even though coEM can improve
with more unlabeled data,
EZLearn's improvement
is significantly higher.
And then, we can see that,
that probably happens
because EZLearn
picks up those cases from
a longer tail with more more
unlabeled training data.
And so, to conclude,
EZLearn combines Distant
Supervision and Co-training
to allow you to
solve a problem in
this organic supervision regime,
where you have
a bunch of data that
was put in the
repository without
a new machine or
readable labels but there are
human readable labels that
sometimes contain
relevant information for you.
So, you don't have
to label the data,
you can just do this Co-training
plus Distance
Supervision approach.
And it's also very useful
for cases where you
have change in Ontology
or grow in Ontologies.
So if you want to find,
but you know Biologists
who maintain
an Ontology of tissues,
add another tissue type
in Ontology,
we can just throw around
the method without actually
finding manual labels for
that particular tissue.
Yeah, thanks. Any questions?